build a team if you want to have success
as an entrepreneur you need to build a
team you need to build beyond yourself
because you cannot do everything
yourself and you shouldn't be doing
everything yourself one of my favorite
stories is about Ben & Jerry's ice cream
they were founded by two friends Ben and
Jerry who in 1977 decided hey we want to
get into the food business these guys
were lifelong friends and they thought
the bagel business was too expensive so
they said okay let's go into the ice
cream business and they spent five
dollars to get this correspondence
course on how to make ice cream and so
they set up shop they learn how to make
ice cream they invested eight thousand
dollars of their own money in four
thousand dollars and borrowed money they
took over this this you know ghetto gas
station and started Ben & Jerry's ice
cream the problem was they started
losing money these guys were were the
prototypical entrepreneur doing
everything themselves making the product
driving the truck doing the sales and
marketing balancing the books everything
and they realized we're not great with
numbers we suck at numbers we're not
good at this and we're losing money and
they had to put a sign up on their door
to close down the shop one day to say
we're closed because we're trying to
figure out what's going on talk about
being authentic and it started to change
when I realized hey we're not good at
the numbers we shouldn't be focusing on
this if it if this company depended on
us knowing our numbers and this being
our core competency we're going to fail
so they brought on somebody to help them
they had a friend who was a local
nightclub owner named Fred lager who
came on board he became their first coo
and the company started to turn around
he watched the books he did all the
numbers he handle all the money and the
company finally started to make a profit
and it helped put the company on track
to what it is now a global brand with
tons of sales but it may not have ever
gotten there at Ben and Jerry tried to
do it all themselves and this is the
important lesson for you as a business
owner you can't do everything yourself
there's there's so much that you have to
do to run a business and this is this is
why it's hard this is why so many
companies so many entrepreneurs
shut down because there's so much stuff
that you have to do and you end up
spending so much time doing the stuff
that you hate doing the stuff that
you're not good at that you spend so
little time on the stuff that it's
actually high-value where you're the
expert and you want to focus as much
time on that I call that CEO time as
much time on that as possible and not
all the other crap that still needs to
get done but shouldn't you get shouldn't
shouldn't be being done by you so
whether that's bringing on somebody
part-time full-time as an employee as a
consultant as a partner in the business
your business will never be great as
long as you are doing things that you
are not great at does that make sense
you want to focus on what you're really
good at what you love doing where you
had tons of value where you really help
people where you know by doing this you
could change the world and everything
else should be given to other people who
are greater that and let them run with
it that's how you build a quality
organization you have to start building
a team and stop trying to do everything
yourself believe for those you watching
I love to hear what you have to think
I'd love to hear how you're trying to
build your team up leave it in the
comments below or ask me a question in
the comments below you can click on the
link in the description to support me in
these videos give the video a thumbs up
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon